l'iran en position de force face aux
européens et aux américains c'est en
tout cas l'analyse beaucoup russia mlouk
il est avocat
les iraniens maintenant ils vont à la
table des négociations et ils disent ce
qu'ils disent en fait plutôt par aux
européens et aux américains ils disent
vous étiez et ceux qui sont sortis de ce
noeud cet accord sur le nucléaire et on
voit pas pourquoi maintenant que vous
voulez revenir à la table des
négociations
vous voulez que nous on fasse le premier
pas alors que vous vous êtes sortie et
vous voulez
en lever les sanctions pour qu'on puisse
se mettre à négocier les iraniens se
sentent en position de force puisqu'ils
savent que si les américains dans les
faits les sanctions comme l'économie du
pays ne s'est pas effondré et que
maintenant les iraniens se sont tournés
vers les chinois et les russes pour ça
pour faire des affaires l'économie du
pays continue et il dit si vous n'en
avez pas les sanctions on sera pas le
premier